now Chris last year you were crowned
congratulations People's sexiest man
alive thank you yes how exciting yes of
course so in the last few months is that
you know what have you learned about
yourself are people treating you any
differently so many things yeah I always
knew it but now everyone else does too
so it just feels right from your Marvel
fan who would you like to see NAB the
title next Mark Ruffalo Robert Downey Jr
who wouldn't snap the title both those
guys would be perfect contenders you
could throw Paul Bettany in there Aaron
Taylor John I mean come on Marvel's it's
you know let's do a whole Marvel cover
with all of you that's true it's true
it's man alive yeah fight to the death